[Music]
we did actually arrive at a formula
improvements that we all felt confidence
about we actually did such a large base
quantitative testing the product came
they were looking to launch which is
called two times power to review younger
looking skinn in 28 days and a very
proud flame that we actually have it on
the package couple of lessons learned
start with the needs of the consumers or
the end-users you're trying to delight
the traditional business thinking and a
traditional business approach starts off
with a business solution first the
consumer research was done late stage
after the assumptions of the business
solution was locked and so if you think
about it if your assumptions for
business solution is actually flawed
everything actually doesn't matter
anymore for have one year the company I
was not courageous enough to actually
challenge the assumptions that the GM
actually has set out and courage is
actually a very important trait for
design thinkers more importantly focus
on the what's not on the how and really
get back through real and good problem
definition
[Music]
are those business challenges and
business objectives valid what do I need
to do actually to set up the right
problem definition and this is really
when I think design comes in as a
strategy it comes in at a strategy for
us to reexamine the problem definition
using consumer understanding to really
get to the heart of what are you trying
to solve for the very first step that we
did really is to take a step back and
re-examine that network effect as power
of empathy developments who are the two
most important stakeholders is critical
for us then to start investigating into
the insights into what are the ways in
which consumers perceive relevancy to a
brand from not just functional but to
emotional as far as to social needs from
observations we know that from the
habits and practices of our consumers in
each step of the the usage regimen as
she uses her skincare products
she's always trying to tap products into
the skin and that actually has
implications it has implications of the
sensory on the product sensory how will
it feel it actually has impact on
technology the skincare actives that we
actually chose such a degree can deliver
the insulin effects for our consumers
and actually also impacts a product
story how can we convince her we are
really delivering this need that she was
looking for I actually also in fact um
impact the packaging and that actually
has impacts on brand communications
speaking to her and speaking to her life
in her struggles
our share with you I think three
critical reflections and thoughts I have
four Design Thinking cross cultural
fluency is paramount to design thinking
a simple English word on the left smooth
in Chinese easily there are five
interpretations of it it really means
that sometimes an idea that we have in
our local language that we're familiar
with they may not really be translatable
actually to another language
you actually lose that idea in in
translation and that's critically
important for us to be aware of as
design thinkers the power of design
thinking really is unleashed with
breakthrough technology even if we had
the right idea about the source of the
origin cells if we did not have the
technology or the skincare active
ingredients to actually bring about that
idea we will not be able to communicate
that as well
diversity of talents is crucial to
design thinking not everybody is a
t-shaped person not everybody is a
design a design thinker so I do think
that we still need to appreciate the
diversity of the talents and the skill
set that we have so that we can read
then harness that and drive Design
Thinking to the next level
[Music]